when Katie Dippold and I first wrote the
script we had a scene where he wanted to
show the origin of Slimer and since all
our ghosts in the movie most of them are
based on humans who come back from the
dead
thus ghosts to me ghosts of humans have
died we wanted to find some fun origin
of how Slimer became Slimers so we
actually had it where they were in this
they got called to a restaurant that had
in the many years ago had some famous
gangster had come in I was demanding
lots of food big giant guy and the
waiter screwed up and so he ended up
killing the waiter and then he was sent
to jail and executed and so we liked the
idea that the ghost of this gangster had
come back and was sort of raiding the
kitchen in this hotel in this restaurant
and then when the Ghostbusters come in
they haven't quite tested their
equipment yet so they haven't got the
levels right and so they shoot it trying
to catch her capture it but it's too hot
so the proton peeps are too hot so it
blows his legs off and then it turns him
green and then he starts to distort and
so he becomes Slimer and then he escaped
out into the out into the world and so
we just like the idea that Slimer had
some sort of a disreputable past